on friday the 9th of april 2021 we
received a very sad news that his royal
highness the prince philip duke of
edinburgh
had passed away at the age of 99.
his contribution to our nation serving
loyally at the side of her majesty the
queen for more than 70 years
cannot be underestimated in addition
the young people in the district have
benefited significantly from
participating in the duke of edinburgh's
awards scheme for a number of years
a scheme founded by him which has
enabled many young people to build the
skills confidence and resilience
they have needed in order to make the
most of their lives
our thoughts are with her majesty the
queen and the royal family
who have lost a husband father
grandfather and great-grandfather
i have written to the queen's private
secretary to express condolences to her
and the royal family on behalf of rocha
district council
the council's flag has also been lowered
to half mask
as a sign of respect i've also cancelled
any civic engagements of a social
or fundraising nature during this sad
time
a period of national mourning has begun
and will continue until the funeral
takes place at 3pm
on saturday the 17th of april
the royal family has asked that during
this difficult time floral tribute
should not be left at royal residences
and that we should all continue to
follow public health guidance
particularly on avoiding meeting in
large groups and or minimizing travel
i would therefore urge residents not to
travel to london
or any of the local residences in order
to respect the wishes of the royal
household
i know that many residents will be
feeling saddened and will want to
commemorate this sad loss
however can i please urge you to follow
the wishes of the royal family relating
to floral tributes
and to refrain from leaving floral
tributes within our district
the website the royal house side has
suggested that residents may wish to
consider
instead making a donation to a charity
of their choice
or to one of the duke of edinburgh's
patronages
due to the need to maintain prevailing
public health coronavirus restrictions
and government has stipulated
there will be no physical book of
condolence at the council
the raw household has set up an online
book of condolence which can be found at
www.royal.uk
stroke condolence so that residents can
leave their personal messages during
this national time of mourning
formal arrangements are currently being
finalized so we can commemorate and
commemorate the life of his
highness the prince philip duke of
edinburgh please go to the royal
household website at www.royal.uk stroke
home high from raw hyphen family if you
would like
more information in the meantime roxanna
district council will be holding a
two-minute silence in
honor of his royal highness and prince
philip duke of edinburgh
which will be streaming on our youtube
channel on friday the 16th
of april at 9 30 a.m so that residents
can
watch live the link can be found on the
front page of the council's website
www
stroke user stroke rockford council